and the more that the news started
coming out
with what covid was and how it is what
like what kind of havoc it was raking on
the world and how fast it was spreading
it kind of scared us away from trying
when the pandemic began samantha worked
from home and took care of her toddler
after his daycare shut down
the uncertainty of the pandemic health
risks and excessive stress took a toll
and she and her husband decided to delay
their plans for a second child it's
super exhausting for the both of us so
we couldn't have found time even though
that we were
both
home a statistics canada report found in
2021 nearly 24 percent of canadians
changed their fertility plans due to the
spread of covet 19. obstetric doctor
tally bogler says uncertainty was a big
factor the economic uncertainty the
general uncertainty uncertainty about
the future
and fear of cova 19 infection in
pregnancy she says many avenues for
support were also disrupted the system
was overwhelmed fertility clinics were
closed all the pregnancy supports that
typically exist were were disrupted like
prenatal classes and breastfeeding
supports people were afraid of having
family members come into the home to
help according to a global ipsos study
financial concerns were a top reason why
many people delayed plans for a baby
wealth advisor jeanette powers says
financial planning is key before having
a child daycare costs in 2020
were an average in toronto of sixteen
hundred dollars a month
you can imagine if you have two or three
children how quickly that that adds up
educational planning you may need to
upgrade your vehicle and you may need to
upgrade to a larger living space power
says budgeting is not meant to
discourage you but rather show you the
areas where you can save and set you up
for success that's prudent no matter if
we're in a pandemic or if we're not
charming somani global news